I hosted a show with Shirley at a comedy
club that was done what did you do yell
out 16 I was just [ __ ] with people in
the audience
good evening country did you get into
the word [ __ ] when you were on stage I
could write away or did you testing one
two three
I don't know if I said [ __ ] Shirley says
Ronny was evaluating women on stage a
minute into the set yeah I was gonna say
he said he kibbutz with the audience why
did the cut cross the road why to get to
the [ __ ] you're good I go see you thank
you what happened you invited Ronny to
your show I tell you he controls the
room for sure he got some commands the
room yeah because it's as if 20:19 and
everything that's going on with her ass
look at you sweetie stand up oh my god
hey I'm Ronnie Rickles so how long is
Ronnie out there warm so proud for you
so this shows about start right how much
time you want me to do I'm like two five
minutes five bring up the first cuz I
barely get to know me you didn't say
this but it's like you know he's like
let me see your [ __ ] and now coming up
to the stage follow ya I said you didn't
say that relax calm down relax right oh
my god so sensitive you did a good job I
know I did did he get out there and yell
the first time he gets out there like
does he start it right away
oh you heat the router let's [ __ ] some
horse pretty quick okay they were asking
for it did they not ask for it they were
asking people ask for me people want you
to yell at something stupid so you just
say hey I'll give them what they want
I'll give them what they want it for
can't you handle these shows on your own
you may have Howard listen let me tell
you something now because you know he's
up there we con didn't wait a minute
instead of doing stand-up they don't
curse but you you don't do the joke do
you just go right to the dirty world you
go write your con no actually the common
[Music]
they're like a VIP ticket where Ronnie
will curse you out I will call you cut
now to your face did you pay for the
meeting be where I [ __ ] you up
get over here you're some clip from the
shulie show when you're backstage ready
to go on you don't want them letting the
audience feel like they can just yell
whatever the right they want to cut them
down because that continues once the
host leaves this right they're all fired
up now now there's this show like now
there's just a Q&A to town hall when
Ronnie Ozark on what do women annuity
what do you yell out what would you yell
out [ __ ] some horse or yeah or 69 women
do do they like it Ronnie would say to
you look Julie I wish I had something to
say but I get on stage and I find within
30 seconds I have absolutely nothing to
say
screaming cursing and yelling to women
in the audience that they're hot and
it's embarrassing
no he just goes out and does it and
doesn't care no why should I care
[ __ ] host I'm not a comic I said it
was a comedy different kind of [ __ ]
host I'm sorry that's for sure
but I mean it's more of like a hostage
situation the audience is waiting for a
comic and you come out and then there's
stock with you I think they had their
comics and I sat there and I kept my
mouth shut during the whole thing I'm
just saying but you don't get any shame
like you don't sit there and go you know
like I have nothing to say like I would
be like hey I don't have an act prepared
I like these
your act is a lack of preparation okay
you don't I mean like Regis would go to
Vegas insane like I'm gonna sing what
but I mean at least I mean something Jay
Z's consent these I don't need an act
man like I managed to put together
something in the way she squirts that's
enough